and here we are and here we are
congratulations well thank you and to
you oh yeah we've survived we've thrived
thrived so I just want to start by
reading from the website because I love
this line and I want you to explain it
to me but I think I get it okay Jones
Road is a lifetime of beauty knowledge
distilled what does that mean just that
it's I've learned so much and I just
know how to make it really simple so I
just kind of broke it down into like the
simple things that matter so 30 years
ago you couldn't have created this brand
100 not yeah yeah 100 not so much has
changed personally for me and in our
world that Jones wrote is really a
reflection of of me and my aesthetic and
what I think women
um should know things you would have
never known 20 30 years ago things I did
not know no there is something good
about about getting older there's
there's a lot good about it actually did
you ever when you were growing up
um maybe starting in your first job or
coming out of college did you ever
imagine like your career after 50 years
old 55 60 65 did you like plan for that
first of all my first job was selling
shoes and then I went to school to study
makeup so did I think I was going to
ever do anything remarkable not really
and when my husband and I sold our first
business I signed a 25-year non-compete
which
I counted on my fingers I would have
been 60 when the non-compete was up I
wouldn't want to work when I was 60 I
thought when I was 32 years old
yeah you signed a 25-year non-complete
yeah I was going to be in my 60s which I
was when it went away which was the day
I launched my new makeup company I was
64 years old
did you regret signing the non-compete I
don't regret anything but
I didn't know any better and honestly
when you're in your early to mid 30s how
can you even imagine being in your 60s
that just sounded so old to me and and
by the way it was old when we were in
our 30s 60 was older and now
I have a friend who's in his 80s just
went to Burning Man
like it's not there's I think there's a
Groundswell about positivity from aging
and by the way it comes from inside of
you no one's going to hand it to you you
have to just see the positive side of it
I think there's it's something to be
said for owning it and you know not
being afraid of it right it's you know
it's wisdom it is it's beautiful it is
it's really beautiful and by the way
there's so many like things to be
focused on except what's not right you
know the back or whatever no if your
back hurts guess what do yoga right I
mean or go see a chiropractor there's so
many things you could do to feel better
and and it requires a lot of work by the
way to to make yourself feeling better
well it's about if I'm a uh it's about
sort of turning that frown upside down
and I feel like in our 30s we're rushing
around and we're seeing what's wrong and
trying to fix everything right and I
find in my 50s I'm like enjoying
everything that's so right and I really
don't see the things that I thought
were stressful I just think back going
oh poor child right yeah why why did I
waste all my energy on that and I think
the pandemic also helped a lot of us put
things into perspective and you know I I
don't want to think about in five years
how old I'm going to be you know people
that say when you know when do you want
to sell this new company and I'm like I
don't I don't I don't because I'm
thinking about now not in five years
right so
um you I think you told the Ft that you
never want to be part of a billion
dollar brand again
I I did say that but it's heading in
that direction get back take it back I
could take it back I don't want to do
what I did I want to do everything I'm
doing differently it is about doing
things differently when you get to a
certain stage and you have experience
not just ups but the Downs right and
also like all the things I've learned I
know exactly what to do but even more
important I know what not to do I know
what not to waste my time and energy and
money on tell me what not to do what do
you not do anymore in terms of like your
business strategy and life I don't hire
Consultants I don't hire focus groups I
have the internet my people tell me what
they think and feel I just
tell someone what I want and what I
think and what we should do and approve
things without a committee you know one
of the things I like being the boss
I like having people around me that give
their opinion and tell me what they
think but I like being the boss it's fun
yeah makeup is not to be decided on by
committee
yeah that seems a little that seems
tough actually yeah it was not the
easiest part of of my last job
so there are some things in the way you
do business now that you would never do
again you just won't go back to it no I
won't go back and there's just so many
new ways to do things that by the way
don't cost as much money doing getting
the message out there getting the word
out there and you don't have to do what
you did before so let's talk about that
um it's you're direct to Consumer right
we have one store one store one one
store one store in Montclair New Jersey
yeah which is going gangbusters so where
does most of your sales happen direct to
Consumer okay yeah directly consumer
like on tick tock well Tick Tock has
kind of uh quadrupled our business when
I went on Tick Tock I mean it's probably
doubled now but at first it was
quadrupled can I ask like what those
numbers look like yeah they look good
they look good they look good like like
how good like really good give me a
ballpark I'm so bad with numbers and a
lot we whatever we did you know in our
first year which I don't you know I'll
tell you off camera okay we are going to
triple it this year
and a lot because of tick tock
um I think a lot because of Tick Tock
but a lot because my team like I bring
the knowledge and the marketing and the
formulas and the product and my team
brings the marketing like they bring the
digital marketing they they bring the
marketing you know my head of marketing
my head of PR my head of social like my
team it's my team my you know my CEO
my I mean my my assistant my second
assistant like it's the team that really
makes the brand tick where do you do
most of your direct to Consumer Outreach
um certainly email we have a huge email
list I know we have a four I'm not
really great remembering numbers but I
know we have a 48 open rate which is
really good for an email our emails are
visually beautiful and informative
we also you know we're Instagram we're
you know we're Facebook and you know
things have shifted they used to be
Facebook ads that turned into Instagram
ads that now are turning into Tick Tock
ads you know my team is Young and
Scrappy and finger on the pulse and they
just get things done and it's you
talking a lot oh it's me talking I mean
you know fortunately unfortunately I'm
the one that no you are I I know I'm a
tick tock star I and yes and everyone
has to say you know Bobby Brown Tick
Tock sensation comma 65. they have to
say it and at 65 years old I did not
think I was gonna have to worry about
always having a camera in in my face but
I've gotten good with lighting and I do
most of my tick tocks after I've had a
blowout because I just feel better yeah
you know there's plenty in a ponytail
and there's plenty where there are no no
there's plenty like let me talk I do I
do but I try to make it flattering I'm
not trying to shock I'm just trying to
communicate yeah and it's just a very
very loud big microphone and it's it's
hit a nerve and it's like it doesn't
cost anything honestly it doesn't cost
anything my my head of social is my
daughter-in-law my head of marketing is
my son
you know my husband is doing the
business with me so it's turned into a
family affair that's wonderful yeah
that's so nice yeah most days yes but
that's true there's that yeah
um you seem to work with your husband
too so I work with my husband it's not
challenging at all no it's great
actually it's I feel really blessed
right I really I that's something that
I'm like now we're four hours right
we're like wow I hope we like each other
but you know all those things are
challenges but it's how we deal with
them and the choices we make is how you
know how good or how not good it is like
I've learned how to talk and say things
that weren't as insulting oh so you're
you tend to be
um you have really good advice I I watch
something you actually just told me it
was like we don't view ourselves but the
way you say it yeah is better it's like
I'm listening and I go oh my God no we
don't stop that yeah we view ourselves
terribly I complimented you and you said
what was wrong and I said what was wrong
for me but then I said we just we pick
those things out and it's just no one
else notices it you know yes I'm five
foot tall I'm wearing really high heels
because I'm going to a cocktail party
last night tonight I cannot walk in in
my sneakers or you know my head will
hurt
so but that's my thing like my husband
is happy with me being little like he's
like who cares everyone knows you're
little but I feel better wearing my
heels so your brand is you yeah your
advice and your make it's you me it's me
and it's honestly like what I learned
from Aunt Alice my 91 year old aunt
who's never taken any medication in her
life
literally still takes you know lessons
painting and she just is an amazing
human she's my biggest role model
because she's just like everything's
fine it's fine nothing's wrong it's
really good advice it's really good we
don't because we don't think that way
right I think everything is wrong I'm
curious though also do you and your team
talk about I'm sure you do but
has have have you thought of any
um
adjustments along the way given what
we've learned about the impact social
media not necessarily your social media
but
um Instagram and I don't know so much
about Tick Tock if it has this negative
but a lot of young girls are are
struggling right with their self-image
and their mental health right because of
some of these platforms kind of
influencing them I mean of course we are
very sensitive and there's things that I
might say that I won't say on video and
you know everyone is sensitive to a lot
of things so we're always careful with
what we say we're care you know no one
wants to insult anyone and you know I'm
I happen to be like a you know a nice
person who cares about people so I like
to empower people and not make people
feel bad no and in fact we probably need
more of this type of thing on social
media
um I'm just I am amazed at what like how
you get the yeah they all follow you how
many followers do you have on Tick Tock
um a lot I don't even I I don't know a
lot I'm going to get the numbers off a
lot
so what do you think your greatest
accomplishment was in your life if you
can you have a lot of them but over the
age of 50. well I think first of all
helping women of all ages to feel
comfortable in their skins and to
empower people to let them know that I
really do believe that you could do
anything you set your mind to and you
could figure it out I don't care if
you're in your 20s I don't care if you
come from certain situations where it
doesn't look like you have everything
handed to you there are some amazing
success stories and you know and there's
people that have been handed everything
that have literally flushed it down the
toilet so you know it's what you do with
what's handed to you that matters it it
appears that you feel empowered to speak
your mind and to be who you are if that
if that's pretty much pretty much did
that come with age of course of course I
mean I am different in my 60s than I was
in my 50s and I'm going to tell you how
much better 60s are than 50s really yeah
and 40s like all my decades like 30s 30s
was so interesting because I sold the
company I start I had two kids
um you know I lived out of the city it
was I was learning new things I was
crazy traveling 40s was interesting I
had a baby and things got more settled
but then they were super super busy and
then 50s were like okay I still feel
good in my 50s I look good I'm still
working and 60s were the oh my gosh it
could be anything you wanted to be us
and that's honestly it's there's
something really freeing when you turn
60 and you're just like okay watch me
this is what I want to do and this is
how I want to live my life a lot of
women in their 20s 30s I I now have
daughters feeling this
crunch but they seem to be rushing
around a lot they feel like if they
don't have that job by 30 or by 35
they'll never get there or they'll never
they'll never what's your advice to
younger women who feel so rushed well
it's funny some of the women feel that
way others because of the pandemic have
started Living their life differently
and making different choices and and and
I think that's okay and you know right
now being an entrepreneur and starting
your own business whatever it is is
possible with the help of social media
so a lot of people are starting to
become Consultants or create you know a
granola company I don't think we need
another granola company in the universe
but you know it's an opportunity for
people it is and
there's a long Runway there is a long
Runway and by the way I think about
myself being 70 and 80 and 90 and who I
want to be how I want to feel and what I
want to be doing and I know there's
going to be something that I haven't
done yet because
what else am I going to do except try
things right
well and you're gonna have to take back
that comment you made to the Ft I have a
feeling oh yes yeah I mean it happens to
be you know despite myself it happens to
be going splendidly well
it really is was there ever a moment
before you reached the age of 50
um were you just wanted to give up
I never wanted to give up being in a
beauty industry I might have wanted to
give up being at my company but I stuck
with it what was it that kept you in the
game well there was days and weeks that
were really tough and challenging and
I'm someone for whatever reason I see
the glass you know all full and I always
think I could fix things so I was always
kind of coming in with the resolve I
know how to do that watch me fix this I
I had a visual roll of tape that I could
like just tape up and fix things and it
took it took a long time to realize that
I couldn't
genuinely I really appreciate this I
love your advice thank you very much my
pleasure thanks for having me
[Music]